it was it was about advancement and it
was also about the claim that somehow
they have like special expertise this is
a special technical language no one else
can understand that only only a weekend
but what's absurd about it absolutely
ludicrous all right that these people
these these American academics who are
imitating the contorted language of
French translations from the French okay
really when lack call is translated into
into English right there's a contortion
there okay you know he's what he was
trying to do in French was to break up
okay the neoclassical formulations that
descended from Racine there was
something that was going on those are
sabotage of the French language going on
that was necessary in France not
necessary in English we have this long
tradition of poetry going back to the
Shakespearean Chaucer we have we have
our own language a far more vital than
that than the French
oh yeah the French constrain their
language all the time but my dear Lord
absolutely in amateurism okay of
American academics trying to imitate
okay a a translation of like ah okay
when like costumes something in France
that is actually not necessary and
indeed wrong to be doing in English
right the other cynical abandonment okay
of the great tradition of you know of
the English departments I and III felt
that the true radicalism was not about
adding on other departments okay so we
have African American Studies and you
know and and and women's study and so on
the true radicalism would have been just
to shatter the departmental structure
that's what I wanted I feel that was the
authentic revolutionary nineteen sixties
things to do right Joe like to blend all
the literate literature studies studies
together okay to make easier to make an
interdisciplinary kind of organization
you know closer to the British model
where a person can pursue related
subjects overlapping subjects these
these departmental models okay are were
to meet totalitarian to begin with okay
separating the language into fiefdom
Xand and and what what this did to
create the English what Women's Studies
department absolutely out of the air
just snap your fingers and create women
studies the English department had taken
a century to develop okay there was a
huge argument okay within with within it
right and all of a sudden to create
a department with a politicized agenda
from the start hey by people without any
training whatever in that field I mean
what should be the what should be the
parameters of the field which would be
the requirements of that field how about
biology okay if you're gonna be
discussing gender that should have been
a number-one requirement okay
as part of any Women's Studies
department or program but no okay it was
all hands off it was just the
administrators wanted to solve a public
relations problem they had a situation
with very few women faculty nationwide
at a time when the women's movement had
just started up that spotlight of
attention was was on them they want they
needed women faculty fast they need to
do with them with the women's subject on
the agenda fast right so they just like
poof let there be women studies okay and
now we'll just hire some women and
usually from English departments you
know here and there and we'll just throw
them together you invent it you say what
it is so that's why women's studies got
frozen at a certain point of ideologies
okay of the early 1970s I was already in
revolt from it okay I was a precursor in
terms of my endorsement of feminism
before it before even now was created
right but I couldn't yeah I couldn't
even have a conversation with any of
these women they were hysterical about
the subject of biology they knew nothing
about hormones right I mean I I probably
got in fistfights over this they went
people were so convinced that biology
had nothing whatever to do with gender
differences see that also seems to me to
be related to the postmodern emphasis on
power yeah because there's a there's
something terrible underground going on
there and that is and I think this is
the sort of thing that was reflected in
the Soviet Union too and the especially
in the 20s when there was this idea a
radical idea that you could remake human
beings entirely right because they have
no essential nature and so if your
fundamental hypothesis is that nothing
exists except power and you believe that
then that also gives you the right in
some sense to exercise your power at the
creation of the kind of humanity that
your utopian vision envisions and then
that has no that and that also seems to
me to justify the postmodern insistence
that everything is only a linguistic
construct it again goes down to the
notion of power which Derrida and
Foucault and Lacan so bloody obsessed
with and so and it seems to me what
they're trying to do is to it to tape
all
all the potential power for the creation
of human beings to themselves without
any bounding conditions whatsoever right
there's no history there's no biology
there's and and everything is a fluid
culture that can be manipulated at will
and so meaning in Canada there are
terrible arguments right now about
biological essentialism let's say and
one of the things that happened which
was something I objected to precisely a
year ago is that the social
constructionist view of human identity
has been built now into Canadian law so
there's an insistence that biological
sex gender identity gender expression
and sexual proclivity very independently
with no causal relationship between any
of the levels and so that's in the law
and not only is it in the law it's being
taught everywhere it's being taught in
the Armed Forces it's being taught in
the police it's being taught to the
elementary school kids and the junior
high school kids and underneath it all I
see this terrible striving for arbitrary
power that's associated with this crazy
utopianism and and and but I still don't
exactly understand it I don't like I
don't understand that what seems to be
the hatred that motivates it that you
see bubbling up for example in identity
politics and and in the desire to do
nothing but let's say demolish the
patriarchy